después de introducir la idea de la
rotación de un fluído en un campo
vectorial como este que tengo aquí
dibujado vamos a empezar a hacer que
nuestra intuición cobre algún sentido
digamos en alguna fórmula más concreta
así que vamos a pasar a nuestra pantalla
negra y como siempre vamos a considerar
un campo vectorial que vamos a llamar de
y en este caso tendremos una entrada de
dos dimensiones es decir tendremos dos
variables de entrada y ahora
consideramos para que sea un campo
vectorial una salida también en dos
dimensiones que típicamente le llamamos
a las componentes
pd xy iq de xy verdad este es un campo
vectorial y lo que quiero hacer es
hablar de la idea del rotacional verdad
y la forma en la que denotamos el
rotacional de un campo vectorial es
escribir roth verdad digamos como
abreviatura de rotacional de nuestro
campo vectorial b y por supuesto esto
depende del punto que nos interesa
verdad depende del punto en donde
estemos colocados
para distinguir el caso digamos de tres
dimensiones que será algo distinto a lo
que veremos aquí voy a poner aquí un dos
de que indique que este es el rotacional
en dos dimensiones y el rotacional
deberíamos entenderlo justamente como un
operador
recordemos digamos la derivada clásica
de una función tradicional verdad que lo
pensamos como un operador al cual le
damos una función y nos devuelve otra
función verdad es exactamente la misma
idea con el rotacional lo único que
cambia es que la función que le tenemos
que dar al rotacional tiene que ser un
campo vectorial y nos debe devolver una
función escalar porque queremos que nos
dé un número que nos indique cómo es
digamos la rotación de este fluido
entonces si nosotros volvemos a la
imagen del campo vectorial verdad
podríamos considerar digamos este punto
verdad y podemos observar que alrededor
de él el fluido digamos que podríamos
pensar que está rotando en el sentido
contrario
las manecillas red del reloj verdad
entonces a este tipo de rotación le
queremos asignar un valor positivo en
cambio por ejemplo si consideramos un
punto como por aquí verdad entonces
vemos que la rotación es justamente en
el sentido de las manecillas del reloj y
en este caso queremos asignar un valor
negativo verdad entonces una forma
digamos de entender esto es justamente
viendo un ejemplo muy particular y que
captura toda la esencia del rotacional
así que pensemos que nosotros tenemos un
punto cualquiera en el espacio digamos
este será el punto x coma
muy bien y digamos que tenemos
justamente digamos por aquí digamos por
aquí tenemos que el campo vectorial
apunta justo hacia arriba digamos que
por aquí apunta hacia la izquierda que
por aquí apunta justamente hacia abajo y
por aquí apunta justamente a la derecha
este será como nuestro ejemplo
es esencial para entender o para poder
asignar un valor al rotacional y vamos a
pensar que nuestro campo vectorial en
este punto x se anula es decir que al
evaluar las funciones pq en este punto
valen 0 entonces qué es lo que está
pasando aquí tenemos digamos un punto
verdad en donde el campo vectorial
apunta justamente hacia arriba en este
caso estaríamos pensando que nuestra
función q en este punto particular es
positivo sin embargo si nos movemos al
del otro lado verdad aquí en la flecha
apunta hacia abajo lo cual nos dice que
la segunda componente tiene que ser
negativa en este punto muy bien qué
pasaría por ejemplo con este punto de
aquí bueno aquí nos dice que la primera
componente que es la que nos indica la
dirección horizontal pues tiene que ser
positivo porque apunta hacia la derecha
en cambio en esta parte de aquí la
componente p tiene que ser
muy bien ahora si esto digamos debe
tener un valor positivo es decir
estaremos pensando en un valor positivo
para el rotacional en dos dimensiones
verdad entonces quizás lo que nos pueda
ayudar es capturar la información de las
derivadas parciales de p y las derivadas
parciales de q verdad para que nos dé
una idea de cómo cuantificar esta idea
del rotacional muy bien entonces por
ejemplo por ejemplo fijémonos en la
variable en la componente p y al
aumentar nuestra cantidad digamos vamos
a movernos en la dirección vertical
verdad vemos que la componente p va de
positivo a negativo al aumentar y en
verdad quiere decir que la derivada
parcial de p con respecto de y en este
caso es negativo verdad en este caso es
negativo y recordemos que esto es para
este caso particular y
no sé digamos muy simple que hemos
construido ahora qué pasaría con la
función q en este caso vamos a aumentar
x en esta dirección y podemos ver que
vamos de un valor negativo para q luego
tenemos cero y luego tenemos positivo
quiere decir que la derivada parcial de
q con respecto de x verdad al aumentar x
aumenta q y entonces la derivada parcial
de q con respecto de x tiene que ser
positivo para este caso particular bueno
pues resulta ser que en general en
realidad estas dos derivadas parciales
es lo único que necesitamos para definir
el rotacional en dos dimensiones
entonces el rotacional en dos
dimensiones de nuestro campo vectorial
de evaluado por supuesto en el punto que
nos interese es justamente la derivada
parcial de q con respecto de x verdad
eso nos daría un valor positivo para
este para este caso y como esto es
negativo y queremos que todo cobre
sentido entonces vamos a restar
la derivada parcial de p con respecto de
jett de esta forma esto contribuye
todavía más a que el valor sea positivo
verdad que es justamente la situación
que hemos planteado y está esta es
justamente la fórmula del rotacional
para cualquier campo vectorial en
cualquier punto que nos interese que lo
podemos en realidad pensar como una
medida digamos en cualquier punto de
interés de que tanto se parece el
alrededor de un punto a este
planteamiento perfecto digamos que hemos
dibujado aquí mientras más se parezca
digamos a esta situación será un valor
mucho más grande del rotacional y en
esta situación digamos si invertimos
todas las flechas verdad en realidad si
ahora pensamos que las flechas van en
sentido digamos de las manecillas del
reloj verdad en éstas
en este sentido entonces el rotacional
se vuelve negativo en el próximo vídeo
te mostraré algunos ejemplos de cómo
usar esta fórmula